[Music]
my parents
are jeannie bavaro and villa costa my
mom
is a producer director personal manager
still here in town my dad is a singer
impressionist
my parents had a show called lasting
impressions it was at the luxor
and then it was at the flamingo this was
actually
the finale costume in lasting
impressions and so all the
showgirls used to wear this and i was a
kid and i was backstage and i'd say
hello to them and now
all this time has passed and legends
kindly bought
these beautiful costumes and revamped
them and made them look
awesome for the show that we're in now
and i
am now here in legends in concert and i
get to wear them and it's
truly full circle to be able to now come
back
and wear something that was not only a
part of las vegas history but a part of
my own personal history and my family's
story is
it's really cool i really am proud to be
a part of this show
it's one of the few that brings back the
classic era of the showgirl
and glamour and just taste
in a show we dance our butts off
um we get to wear these gorgeous
costumes and it's just a lot of stuff
that i feel like is not commonplace
anymore
you know you see these huge productions
you have all these residencies and
they're great
they're wonderful but there is something
to be said for
just taking it back and going a little
bit more old school
and just remembering the classics and
what built this city and what makes
vegas vegas